[Music]
hi and so like when I looked again at my
slides like before this talk I was
wondering okay so I say why tenth floor
you got execution matters but I don't
really start with what even is
tensorflow is eager execution your
execution
so normally when we write Cara's models
this gets compiled into a static tensor
flow graph which makes for can make for
pretty unflexible code and our execution
means that the code gets executed
dynamically and this will be the default
operating mode of the Newton's flow 2.0
which is gonna come and let's I don't
know let's say two months or so so end
of this month we're gonna have tens flow
one to thirteen and then the Google guys
are now already extremely busy was
preparing us for 2.0 and the cool thing
is that this tends flow you go execution
we can already do it in our since about
last summer so we've been preparing for
it so we're ready and now in this talk
it's about like I want to show you why
it's so cool that we can do that okay so
I don't know how many of you have been
to the deep learning workshop yesterday
and the day before and perhaps what
you're thinking having been to that
workshop is so deep learning is easy
right because yeah what is deep learning
it's like we're gonna say we're gonna
differentiate between these two cute
creatures do we have a red panda or
giant panda do we have a cat or dog do
we have a boy or girl this is the Adi
standard task we see when we look at
blog posts or whatever in the area of
deep learning and actually yeah that is
pretty easy so we have the carer
sequential API so if you are in the
workshop you've seen that a thousand
times how we code that we define our
model we compile it and then we
you run the training okay so
straightforward right even if we want to
do a bit more complex things
so what's always feel popular
questioners who do I look like actually
I tried that once I'd like corn syrups
like that and you wish is for Microsoft
and turns out like seems like I look
mostly like this extras there and like
three guys Microsoft deep learning
things in 2019 okay so this is kind of
complex question but still if we want to
code it it's pretty doable we have the
Charis API with let's specify several
input several outputs and we can do that
okay but after we leave straightforward
classification and regression problems
we may run into more complex code for
example what's really all the hype
nowadays it's generative models perhaps
you see that I have seen that on Twitter
like began so you see faces quite high
resolution no dice which look like real
people
yeah scenes generated and the main
models for this I either generative
adversarial network scans or variational
auto-encoders so if you've been in the
distributed session I don't know if you
see about Kevin he loves Ganz I love the
is so is this cool cool stuff and what I
want to do now or what I wanted to do
normally when we generate stuff was
often you see what's use is endless
these digits 0 to 9 because just the
easiest thing you can do but what I was
trying here so I want to generate
penguins and that's a cool dataset by
Google Google quick-draw we have
different categories of images and this
is the input this is the input for my
network so I'm gonna try to generate
penguins now generative adversarial
Network it's really pretty cool thing
it's game theoretic in a way it's based
on two antagonistic actors so I have two
agents in my drama I have a generator
who based on noise is gonna generate
real looking images so it's really
getting random data and then we run the
network over it and I get something real
looking and on the other hand of course
I need someone who's going to judge if
it's a good if the result is good or not
this is the discriminator and the
discriminant is trained to tell apart
real images and generated images and so
these two are going to fight each other
and each gonna get better every time
because as the discriminator gets better
discerning between fake and real images
the is going to generate better images
okay so I think the concept for us
humans is pretty graspable right let's
make make sense now if we want a coder
so in that static graph way which we
have been doing until now this is really
not so easy because I need to need to
define different models and then at
every step I need to think about what
actually I'm training and what I need to
freeze weights and actually the code is
pretty complicated
I wrote it down here as a kind of list
of routes but really so if you ask me
now to live coded I'm probably just
going to look at look like look it up in
JJ's book right so can we do that in an
easier way yeah we can with eager
execution we can actually code in a way
which is more like the way we think of
things conceptually and there's one
thing I need to introduce which is which
applies to eager execution as well as
static
execution we can have carrots custom
models in our let's say like sons last
summer approximately and here you see
the way we define them we give them a
set of layers and then we define a call
method which and there we say how the
layers should be chained one of the
other you can use that with static
execution too but it's really central in
eager execution we have it documented
here so you can click on that link and
see how to use it and now when I do this
what I really can do is I can like the
drama which is actually going on I can
write my code like that so first I have
my generator so the guy who's gonna try
to produce these fake images and I
define it as such a custom model so I
said I set it up then I go ahead and
define my discriminator also such a
custom model has its own logic nice ok
and then I go on and now um again in
this antagonistic setting most have
different objectives we always have this
lost function and deep learning and here
each of one has has their own loss
function which you see is coded here and
after I did that I can already start the
the action I'm gonna iterate over the
number of epochs and then I'm going to
iterate over the data set so I always
have these two nested loops and then I
execute the action and when you will
look at code in this ego execution it's
always going to look like this this way
so I'm iterating then I'm gonna create
this gradient tape which is your
recording what the actors are doing I
call the actors let them do their action
I calculate their losses and I'm gonna
do backdrop it's always such a loop like
this
and the pretty mitt matches what how we
are picturing the action mentally and
what what will happen if I do that well
we can take a look here first this is
what I get after first epoch looks
pretty not not random but not so good
really but it's after 80 bucks I get
pretty nice looking penguins I think
they perhaps they even look better than
the input so um it actually works
similarly if I use this other approach
the variation autoencoders I don't have
this antagonistic setup of the generator
and the discriminator working against
each other but I still have an encoder
and a decoder so the encoder is trying
to reproduce some latent code and the
decoder is trying to reproduce
reconstruct the input and the setup is
pretty similar you will see so in this
case oh I was thinking I've generated
these images these penguins and so I
want to generate some snowflakes for
them unfortunately it's really hard to
get training data for snowflakes I even
emailed an book also will produce some
nice photos of snowflakes but so I had
to generate my own training data was
method which is like uses cellular
automata okay doesn't really matter this
is my input data and then again I'm
constructing my model and now you will
see the same principles like before I
have my encoder model which is a
standalone model I can define like that
the decoder model I can define like that
and now with the variation autoencoders
the action really is in the loss
function because with you on the one
hand I want to reconstruct the input on
the other hand I have a regularization
term which is different between
different types of auto-encoders here I
have one specific loss can be a
different one but still this ends up
being like five lines of code or
so and I'm all set up and after I've set
it up like that again I'm just doing the
same kind of iteration over the code so
so first time perhaps you've known so
perhaps you haven't seen that before so
it looks like strange but it's gonna end
up all the same always and now let's see
the snowflakes so I have here they don't
look much worse than the input actually
yeah okay so these were examples of
models which are quite hard to code if
you're using static execution as we have
been doing until now but this gets a lot
easier with is like eager execution but
there's more to it small stuff but
important stuff when doing the coding
for example what's really hot is to see
what's going on in deep learning if I
look at I think of github issues we tend
to get what may happen is like people
want to code their own lost function or
their own metric you can do that and
caris okay well then you get a shape
error somewhere in there so the shapes
don't can happen and now people tend to
get stuck because they just don't know
how to debug this and eager execution
you can do it you can just print it out
like printf debugging so it's I mean
you're gonna remove it later right so
why not do it that's one thing another
thing is you can have more modular code
because because you can isolate logic in
small custom models and then also as
when sometimes we are getting if you
want to have architectures where you
can't just change the layers one after
each other
you need some interleaving of logic I'm
going to show that so these are three
examples for how ego execution makes
things easier actually
now easy debugging for example here you
have this loop again where I'm doing the
recording of the actions
and I'm going to go calculate the loss
and then doing the backdrop and now
really what happens when you actually
code this in practice you're quite often
you may get shape not matching shapes
and deploying and then what I can do
here is I can just really print it out
and I cannot just only just print out
the shape I can print out the actual
images so when I do this printing or
edit images I really see like my hands
float and Rosia like a 4d array of
floats and this is like invaluable for
debugging actually when you're writing
that code also here with the gradient so
one thing if your network just doesn't
train yeah what one thing that can
happen is that the create is just vanish
or get too big for example and so what I
can just do I can print them out and
there I have it
another thing modular code so what we
often see in more in longer deep lining
examples is like I have lots of layers
for example econ vennett and all these
convolutional layers they want their
parameters specified and so it gets long
and lots of duplicated stuff and here
what I can do I can just take a part of
the logic and put it in a custom model
for itself here what we often do is
either app sampling or down sampling so
convolution or deconvolution and typical
for example down sampling module could
look like a conveyor and some batch
normalization and drop another cone
flier another batch normalization
another dropout and now I don't have to
type that again and again and again I
can just define it as an own sub module
so to say and then I can go on and use
that if I go back to my generator this
was from the variational auto encoder
this does does a
bunch of down samplings and a bunch of
up samplings again and here I use my
custom module which are different
defined on the previous slide so code
gets a lot more readable like that too
and then yeah nice example for this
interleaving logic is so like one or two
years ago no actually since 2013 so bit
longer mechanism was was this crud where
we have in a network whether we tell all
the network learns where to direct its
attention so let's say I have this task
of describing image captions or learning
image captions so the network is shown
pictures and it's asked to generate a
description for it like the bird flows
of flies over the light lake something
and the architecture is I have a convert
to extract the features yeah a normal
image processing and then I have an iron
an which is supposed to generate the
caption and now the idea is that as the
RNN goes on generating this caption so
one word after another another place in
the image is important right
like first is the bird and then the lake
so the network shifts its attention from
around different locations in the image
and this really you can code in static
tensorflow but you can't code in
straightforward Kiera's so and it's it
gets a bit nasty but now with eager
execution what you can just do is you
have your decoder this which is the RNN
which is going to generate that sentence
and as this iron and generates every
word it's going to call the attention
module to direct its attention things
like that that have really been really
difficult to do without that
and now ok first documentation so we
already have lots of examples for that
on the blog so these are all links to
the blog articles using eager execution
for things like image to image
translation image captioning your star
transfer and your machine translation
and of course you also have
documentation how to construct an eager
execution model now finally next up so
to say we all have one article getting
started with tensorflow probability as
the flow probability is a separate
module of tensorflow which is integrated
with tensor flow which can run
distributed on GPU and cover things like
from on the bottom level distributions
going up over probabilistic Network
layers until variational inference MCMC
and things like that so and that also we
can this goes together very very nicely
with eager execution and with the same
benefits I can print out stuff and
immediately see what's going on and
we're going to cover that in quite some
detail in the near future
ok and there let me say thanks for your
attention and do you have any questions
[Applause]
so we have time for a couple questions I
have a runner this time
thanks a lot for the great talk I wonder
if the tensile executioner also
integrates into tensor board so you can
have maybe real-time tense of all aboard
chart one and turning that so that for
sure we're walk together because this is
a sensor board such a central element of
the whole let's flow environment that
I'm pretty sure the Google guys will
take care that it works fine how helpful
would be the eager execution for Karis
users would it be useful for debugging
or absolutely that's an excellent
question because right now when we say
carrots we can't can mean two of two
things right we can mean these
standalone Chara's or we can mean the TF
dollar carrots or tears or Karis
implementation and these examples at the
moment they are presuppose that you use
that TF dot Kira's implementation which
is as of today is not the default
implementation by using but you can
already use it and probably we're going
to switch to that as the default
implementation and you can do all of
what I said you can do with that TF not
cara's implementation
you
[Music]